looks like puppin
[Music]
sensationals I'm Ming hello I'm J I'm
nice meet you I'm you know I'm
I'm we're playing with puppies
[Music]
with so baby
hi
baby I'm nice to meet you nice to meet
you do you know what it is
[Music]
yeah in my case I want to try country in
same name song in the intro we use a
little bit country sounds of guitar I
want to do some horor country sounds
with our song
[Music]
our
treasure so actually that days
everything is like scared and like
nervous afraid about test for every
month but I think that's one of good
memory now cuz every month we try to
challenge like many like kind of
homework so I like that memory too in my
case we went in N oh yeah n together
yeah his
hometown that's one of
treasure
[Music]
I must to eat local food like in and out
Che the box and check in the box and my
favorite sport is soccer so my favorite
soccer team is Paris St German when I go
in Paris I buy it Paris s German uniform
in Korea player is Gang I love it
tury in ja P skaki oh skaki so delicious
there Guess
m yes M was so
[Music]
good
I like you puppy I Like Your Puppy no
you puppy puppy you are puppy and I am
happy and where are you going looks like
[Music]
puppy rocky rocky 8s
Rocky Wonderland Wonderland there many
good songs that for the workout so
please
try Monday CH stand back and Tuesday
shoulder and legs Wednesday rest oh and
Thursday is repeat oh
helloy he dangerous
man 18 different country different
language but we understand this I really
feeling they love so always thanks for
18 language is not important right yeah
my favorite moment is so too many 18s or
rise up lightning this moment is so
beautiful shiny star we have another
surprise oh another
surprise
hie same
[Music]
AG come on come on you're friend you're
friend
hi we calculate the time with that
country and then for example opposite
time with Korea so we didn't sleep at
Korea and we just take the airplane it's
okay with J like we can
overcome no no no come here
ah bouny oh our reduction staff Ser
already our dancing like bouncy
challenge they show us our challenge so
that is one of our purchase
memory gorilla gorilla yeah it's really
tough and yeah do you actually hala hala
halah hala yeah it was crazy cuz first
time when we did kalaha we our mouth and
we wear the mask and some hat
so very
Sensational okay hello come come
here his name is joy joy is really
energetic maybe he thought this dog name
is sleep sleepy sleepy his name is
Joy name is I think it's like Oreo or
oro oro name is Oreo and joy and
ohon bony Bon bony Oreo Joy Kelly
[Music]
sleepy
I want to live with puppies I want to
understand him them
more first my friend my retriever friend
is mingi big big dog Black cast member
is uong andan yeah yeah my my nickname
is blackhead yeah blackhe and my friends
Joy
California sleepy Oro or hey
[Music]
friend I can talk with
puppy
wow I think that's not your
[Music]
talent or let's do ending very together
one two
three Pyers Pyers yeah they our younger
brother Pyers and an older brother medo
[Music]
yeah playing like
this when we debut we have so many like
fears cuz of of the situation we are not
in big company and we don't have much
opportunity to showing something if I go
back to there I want to say to them
don't afraid anything cuz our 18 will
protect you just do what you want yeah
don't be afraid of challenge yeah you
can adopt this pop P at hit living
Foundation they so so energetic so it's
a cute let's play with them thank you so
much for watching us with bit and please
check out our new songs too thank you so
much thank you thank you let's make
[Music]
friends